cuando queremos calcular cuánto mide el
ángulo de un triángulo lo hacemos
mediante las funciones trigonométricas
de seno y cosenos si deseamos conocer
seno usamos la función cateto opuesto
sobre hipotenusa para el coseno
dividimos el cateto adyacente entre la
hipotenusa en un triángulo rectángulo
jamás encontraremos ángulos mayores a 90
grados es más ni de 90 grados todos
siempre son menores a 20
pero sabes en donde si encontramos
ángulos mayores a 90 grados en los
círculos por eso para ellos también
usamos las funciones senos y cosenos
ayudan a graficar las para saber cómo se
comportan con ángulos mayores a 90
grados e incluso con negativos
empezaremos con la gráfica de la función
coseno tenemos la siguiente tabla de
valores en x encontramos dos grados 360
270 180 90 45 y sus negativos para fx
tenemos que el coseno de 360 es 1 para
270 es 0 en 180 tenemos un coseno de
menos 1 en 90 tenemos 0 para 45 0.7 y en
0 encontramos 1
en los negativos tenemos menos 45 0.7
menos 90 0 menos 180 menos 1 menos 270 0
y por último menos 300 60,1 vemos como
que en una gráfica identifiquemos los
puntos
el primero es 360 1
luego 270.00 80 con 190 0 45 0.7 y 0.1
nos faltan los negativos hay que
encontrarlos en el plano menos 45 puntos
0.7
- 9000
menos 180 menos uno menos 270 cero y por
último menos 360 uno
ya viste que se forman varias curvas
esto quiere decir que tenemos una
función circular ahora vamos con los
datos que tenemos de la función de seno
en x tenemos los mismos grados que en
kössen para la función fx
sabemos que el seno de 360 es 0 para 270
menos 1 luego 180 con 0 90,1 45 0.7 y 00
en negativos encontramos menos 270 menos
1 luego tenemos menos 180 0 menos 90,1 y
menos 45 puntos 0.7
al graficar los quedan de la siguiente
manera
si juntamos las gráficas vemos que son
prácticamente iguales
la diferencia que encontramos es que se
nos pasa por el origen es decir por 0 0
y cose no pasa por 0,1 excelente como te
diste cuenta la función de semi coseno
tienen bastante en común además de que
son funciones circulares sigue
practicando y aprendiendo